because of nevada's downward trend in
cases state leaders are allowing things
like golden knights games other large
events around town to bring in a smaller
crowd
but how will current restrictions be
monitored orco mana has the explanation
we don't want to risk the possibility
of having to deal with outbreaks
ensuring safety
through surveillance the southern nevada
health district says its environmental
health inspectors will be on site at
events at large venues such as t-mobile
arena and the las vegas motor speedway
as they welcome back spectators amid
covid19 they look at the
distribution of people on
on-site also they look at the
the people whether they are wearing
a marks the health district will also
track any positive cases from the events
but it won't be in charge of enforcement
that's up to local jurisdictions
[Applause]
golden knights fans are ready for
in-person games and say they feel safer
knowing the health district is watching
having that extra extra set eyes out
there just kind of wandering through is
fine
i think it's great i think that you know
that they're looking after our best
interests even at 15 capacity large
venues can still have a lot of people so
experts say having health officials
involved is important
the goal is to make sure that these
events are not super spreader events we
don't want something to happen where
thousands of people are infected at the
events
it's all about being cautious that we
don't throw more fuel on a fire that's
starting to go out
orco mana 8 news now now some have
questioned why
larger venues being capped at 15 percent
right now
health officials say they're trying to
ease back into things but they are
watching our covid numbers closely
so they can adjust their recommendations
and boost that number higher
if and when warranted